one thing that happened today as
expected a guy who never should have
been hired by the cowboys has been fired
by the cowboys not mike mccarthy but
mike nolan the other mike wouldn't it be
funny if they accidentally put the wrong
mic on the paperwork but mike nolan is
out as the defensive coordinator of the
dallas cowboys they brought him in to
run a defense that didn't fit the
personnel that they had been
systematically compiling for years shame
on well i'll say shame on me you may
have seen it coming shame on me for not
recognizing this was not going to be an
easy fix because anytime you make a
major change in your defensive
philosophy you have to get the right
players to run it and it didn't work and
we knew from the get go it wasn't going
to work so after one year mike nolan is
out i'm sure cowboys fans would be
saying the other mike should go too but
nolan is out another guy who's out jim
tomsula who once upon a time was the
one-year head coach of the san francisco
49ers he's gone as well so they're going
to rebuild that defensive coaching staff
shireen now that nolan is out
yeah they gave up the most points in
team history mike it was not a good
defense it was not a good fit i think a
name to keep an eye on depending how
mike mccarthy wants to go with that
front whether he wants to go back to the
4-3 or stick with the 3-4 but i think
dan quinn is a name to keep an eye on
possibly raheem morris if he doesn't get
a head coaching job but i think those
two atlanta guys could be candidates for
this job for the cowboys
yeah i think quinn's gonna have to go
back to being a coordinator pick the
right spot and do a good enough job with
the team that does well to ever get a
sniff at being a head coach again in the
future and i'll repeat what i've been
saying all week in different
contexts and settings i would not hire a
defensive coach give me an offensive
coach because if i hire a defensive
coach and he does well i got to find a
new offensive coordinator and then i got
to do it again and then i got to do it
again you get an offensive coach maybe
you get lucky and you have dennis allen
that for whatever reason no one wants to
interview even though he should be
getting greater consideration than he is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports